There's this fucking guy,
I forget his name is doctor a wrap
or a pie or something like that.
He's like his French consulting,
just like some fucking genius and he's
like decoded cultures, right? And uh,
every culture he's decode and he,
people hire him to consult. Right.
And like America's code is a,
it's a,
the verb is to do and the time is now.
Right.
And we're just kids at the end of the day.
It's like everything we love
big tits and America. Right.
The most popular plastic surgery
is big tits and like France,
most popular project surgery is
getting Titsworth reduced. Right.
Everything about them is like
precision food on the plate.
They're most popular plastics.
That's what I was talking to my
buddy and that's what he said.
And maybe it's changed to like
lips or something more common now,
but maybe the one you have to go under
the dark one. Don't fuck with your lips,
ladies like it when they get a
little lips, if they have an audio,
if you have a fucking beak, then you're
going to have a little something.
You see the the thing in there,
it's like it like let's you know,
they're extra needy. There's like
something going on. They wanted the,
they wanted their lips to beat.
You know there's like a symmetrical
proportion that your face is supposed to
fall into this FIBONACCI
sequence, right? To numbers.
Like if you get a nose job,
I look at you and I go, Whoa,
what's wrong with it was
like something is wrong.
It registers wrong in my head because
your face, so like Ari, perfect example.
It's already got a nose job. You
like, what the fuck is happening here?
What's wrong with your face?
But you've already had like a small
Irish person's nose. He'd be like,
what is happening here?
This doesn't even make any sense.
And even that for his
face, right? His face,
there's a sequence like your
lips match your face. They,
they match how far your eyes
are a part where your nose is.
When you see a girl and she's a little
tiny little skinny thing with little
fingers and all of a sudden she's got
this yes, these big weird lips still.
We like things that like stand out.
Like we like skinny with big tits,
we do drawn to it. Right. What types of
things that are abnormally do most pigs,
but it's a trick.
The big tip one is a trick because
it represents where sexual viability,
it represents you,
your ability to breastfeed a child,
which is attractive to your genes.
It doesn't make any sense. Yeah.
I said you would know that there's a bag
of water underneath her skin that she
had a tube down her throat taped
to her face. She's half dead.
They're cutting our open with a sharp
knife and stuffing this bag of water under
the meat of her breast tissue or they're
cutting her nipple often opening up
like a fucking man hole cover pumping
that fucker in there. It's crazy.
Like we know that that's what
happened and we still think it's hot.
The all those things are nuts. Chilean
bro. Yeah. Yeah. In here we can't help it,
but like it bothers me when it's a,
but when it's a fake,
but it bothers me.
Like if there was a way that a girl could
lift weights at the gym and make her
tits bigger and she went and got
fake tits, wouldn't like him as much.
Wait a minute. Wait a minute. Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah. Knowing you can earn it. Yeah.
You could earn it. I might.
Yeah. It's lazy, but he'll
things lazy. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But thing is, it throws you off
if it doesn't match the legs.
Like if a girl's get a big buttons,
it's got some legs. Like, damn,
this bitch is dead lifting. Yes. You
know, like that's hot. It's like,
I've never said that in my head,
but I know what you're talking and
never said this. Bitches deadlift.
He never said that. They see a girl with
big, big hamstrings. Bitch could squat.
That doesn't, I say that all the
time. Just don't work out it up.
I guess I was like, girls was legs that
looked like ticking carry shit. It's hot.
I'm heavy in the girls carrying me around.
Just going to get tired,
but it, but I like girls that are
athletic but of power, you know,
I like it. It's hot. So if a girl's
got a big ass cause she's squatting,
that's hot. The girls got a big
ass cause she went through surgery.
I'm like pitch, you're going to get
cancer. You're going to ask cancer now.
Do you know that way?
Plants from implants,
they're starting to see cases
of bud cans. Whoa, Jack.
That's what I'm talking
about son, Bro. That's power.
That's too strong for me. Oh,
don't be scared. I'm afraid of that. That
girl hurt you. She will. Yeah, that is,
that's like trying to
fuck up crossfitters fist.
You know what I'm saying?
Like the power she must have in that Bro.
Look at that leg. Dude attaches a hawk.
Outstanding. I mean the butt cheeks.
It's too much. He's a athlete. I like
it. Yeah. I don't know like that.
If that girl's in a miniskirt but if
she's not flexing Cipro looks hot as fuck
you. So you were into a very
strong, I like good jeans.
This kind of the other ones,
I mean this girl she
stacked at girls stack.
The only problem with those gals is that
there is a reality to certain levels of
musculature that most likely they're
only achieved by injecting male hormones.
So the cliques kind of get big or
whatever. Have you never seen that?
Are you allowed to like fuck around?
What's your relationship with your wife?
Definitely not. No. No. Okay. Okay. How
long have you been married? 10 years.
10 Years Clone? Yeah. Okay. And
then how do you, yeah. How do you,
how do you navigate that yet? It could
you please explain to me how you do this?
Masturbation Jack will help. How
does it work? Game. Yeah. The, this,
this level of a athleticism.
I was saying like there's like
a certain line that there are,
they are crossing but most likely
is because of male hormones. Yeah.
I can't get into it. There's, there's some
level to that. Did they grow some hair?
Jujitsu girls. There's a lot of
Jujitsu girls that are competitive.
Jiu Jitsu girls that started
doing a little bit of steroids.
They started taking a
little bit of testosterone.
Like a friend of mine's wife was doing
that and I was like, yikes. You saw?
He's like, yeah, she's really
getting into a Jujitsu.
She's competing and she's starting
to take a little bit of testosterone.
I was like, Oh, you know what
happened? So they get horny.
Really like a dude. Really? But they
got this big dangling cleona no,
it only gets big when they go whole hog.
Like when they go bodybuilder,
bodybuilder, big day. Way
Back in the day. He never,
never fucked a girl was a bodybuilder.
Never once ever did fuck a girl was like,
like very fit and strong.
But she had a normal vagina.
Normal clip. Totally normal.
She has a six pack though.
It's kind of weird. Okay. Yeah.
It's a little too strong
feminine. It's not, it's nothing.
But this clip thing fascinates me. So
the clit itches is there like, is that,
you can't put a picture of that up. Can
we look at that? Can you pull it up?
It doesn't. You know what? It is a
little deck. It's like a little deck.
That's what I'm wondering.
Does it have like the head and like the
fuck you saying you've never looked at
in large clits you never done that.
That's exactly what I'm saying.
If you've never done it, Google
search. I looked fake pussies.
I looked up like training pussies, but
I didn't look up and those are not good.
What do you mean the training buzzy? What
do you mean they're not good? Like date?
It's not good. It's not real.
Yeah, I know it's not real,
but you want to be able to tell. Can
you tell? No, but I feel like, oh shit.
This is what they look like, Bro.
There's a dick on inside and nut.
We did that one down there.
Fuck it.
Yeah. That's what happens. It's not real.
It is real. It is real way. No, no, no,
it isn't. No Way. How about that
one in the lower right hand,
upper right hand corner, the dark
one, Jamie below that. That one. Pow.
How you like me now? That's
a Dick Balls. Yeah. No, no.
That's pussy lips, bro. That's not, that's
not how, that's bullshit. Lips Doug.
Okay, let's see. Lips. Now
that one down there. What
about the giant one below that?
Jamie did the one in the middle.
What's happening there? No, Bro.
That just looks like a
witch finger that mine is.
Normally that's Photoshop has to be
from our shop, dude. Dude, this is
free porn.
Yeah.
Oh Dude. Well, when girls
take a lot of testosterone,
they do develop enlarge
clips. There was a, a,
a show on HBO back in the day,
I think it was called private dicks,
but it was like that girl's,
you're into that though. No,
that's a little much. Yeah.
Yeah. That's hilarious.
She's pretty looking now.
She wasn't flexing.
Tell her to eat a couple of
sandwiches. Oh. Anyway, let's
get out of there. That's,
that's enough. We're going to
start vomiting. But anyway,
there was a show on HBO field called
Private Dicks and one of the people on it,
I think that was from that show,
but anyway,
there was this lady who was talking about,
she became a, a trans man from woman,
and by through taking massive amounts
of testosterone, her clit grew.
She said to the size of a thumb.
Yeah.
Because they're taking,
I don't even understand high levels of
testosterone to sort of achieve that. The,
they get hair on their face.
They're boys DPS. Yeah. You know,
they get broader and thicker and they
keep a lot of that too. I don't get it.
I don't, I don't understand. So your clit
is just, your is just a cock essentially,
right? Well, not really. It just resembles
one. I mean if you looked at that,
if my dick look, I thought I'd go right
to the doctor and be like, which one is,
which is finger joints.
Yeah. It seems like a joint,
it seems like a clip with no
skin or got dick with no skin.
Yes.
Well that made me feel
uncomfortable to look at it shut.
Imagine pulling a girl's
panties and should that thing.
It happened to a friend
of mine's boyfriend,
a friend of mine who I used to
work with on a television show her,
she was the story about her ex boyfriend
met this girl and they're fooling
around and they get back to her and she
was pretty feminine, but she had a clip,
like a Pinky,
the way he described it,
and then he pulled her pants down and
then fucking panicked and then said,
oh my God, I have to pick my friend up at
the airport. Fuck, I can't believe this.
And he just, that was his
excuse is I got to pick one man.
The dude panic, he went into a
full blown panic and just ran out.
He couldn't deal with her clit.
I mean it gets to a certain size where
that's like, you got to look at it.
It's wrapped around her leg and
tied in a bow. You're like, oh,
you got to like kind of like
push it to the side to insert.
You gotta hold it like a
handle all your banner choice.
It's like the reins on a horse,
like you're hanging onto it.
Where are you banging on her?